And here we go. Welcome to another Zoom call. We have a number of questions that came in.
Just a reminder to everybody to look at the member site for announcements.
Starting January 1st, we're going to drop back to one Zoom call week for a while. We recently had
one Zoom call week. So if you just started with us recently, it's just been the last few months
that we had. We added the Monday Zoom call for multiple reasons. Just testing out Monday.
We're going to drop that for now in January and in fact may change our time. The Wednesday time
seems to be the best for everybody. It's not perfect for everybody, but it seems to be the best for
everybody. So starting in January there will be no Monday Zoom call actually starting before that
because we won't be open on Monday the 26th. So that's going to be the answer.
Christmas and we won't be open on that. That's an announcement on this side as well.
Second, they understand that new laws is expanding in the plans for a year now, really. New laws
made it impossible for us to do one-on-one calls with people anymore. The state boards are cracking
down on that really big time. I do a lot of podcast interview practitioners, so they're telling me
the same thing in their states that they just can't do one-on-one calls since they're not licensed
to the state. It's just really, really unfortunate. What's going on? Please remember to ask your
questions on the member site and remember that all of our courses now are free to all you guys.
So you use, you can go to any of the courses on our website and you will see that
if you use the same user name and password that you get into the member site,
you use the same user name password for any of the courses that started in first quarter.
We're going to have it on our new course here. It will show the value of some family members as well.
Okay, so in-depth questions here. So this one, so in-depth, but the next one is,
vitamin C infusions are going well in northern Minnesota,
so this person is from northern Minnesota. It's fantastic. We're able to get that out at MD
Willie. Also, Willie to prescribe low-dose niltrexone. That is great.
But once again, dose seed opinion, desired if I empty cans and survival to this program,
I've had gastric pegged tube placed due to ensuing starvation, distant,
esophageal issues. I cannot give you dosage on low-dose niltrexone since that is a prescription
medication. I can't tell you what is pretty standard. Low-dose niltrexone was actually
is a drug that is prescribed to help people get off of, I think, more beaten things,
like addictions, but it's prescribed in like 50 milligram dosage for that. That's why it's called
low-dose niltrexone because some brave doctor found that given niltrexone at a very low dose
that is 1.5 milligrams in a titrated up to 4.5 milligrams before bed can be a very good
regulated. So your immune cells are, you have immune stimulating cells, you have immune
suppressing cells and I should say different chemicals in your body that will stimulate an immune
response, different chemicals in your body that will call an immune response or cause decreased
inflammation. And then you have what are called T-regulator cells. T-regulator cells
help balance your immune system. So in a case of somebody with a hyperactive immune system,
now that would be typically somebody with like brain trauma, somebody with neurodegenerative
diseases, somebody with autoimmune disease. So an autoimmune disease is when it's in a flared
situation, you have this hyper immune response where a lot of inflammatory chemicals called
cytokines are being secreted. So you've got this hyper inflammatory response going on and that
is really what can cause a lot of the symptoms in people that have an autoimmune disease in its
flared condition. So let's use an example and say a rheumatoid arthritis. And my rheumatoid arthritis
is really flared up my hands. They're just really, really hurting and it's just very inflamed and
red and it's very painful. Well, that is because you're getting this hyper release of these inflammatory
cytokines. What part of your immune system balances that is what are called your T-reg cells,
that's short for T-regulator cells. So T-regs help balance a hyper immune system. They also
help balance a hypodermine system. And it has been found that low dose, no-trexone can be
can be another exogenous T-reg stimulator. So it stimulates your T-reg cells so that it can help
balance that. So people with autoimmune disease, some of people have been helped by taking low dose
naltrexone. They could help calm down that inflammatory process. It's been shown to be possibly
helpful with people with inflammatory disorders in the brain too. It could be helpful. Now there's been
some speculation of using it with people with cancer because sometimes being with cancer
have a very suppressed immune system of them using low dose naltrexone can help acting as a T-regulator
help bring that up. So that is really the use of low dose naltrexone. Typically the dose is
started at 1.5 milligrams taken before bed. And then that's well tolerated. You go up to three
milligrams and up to 4.5 milligrams. That's very well detailed in the literature.
So, you know, give me the recommendation to say what is out there in the literature.
I have recently, two weeks ago, purchased an infrared soda brand name TheraSanche. By normal,
morty, routine is now to drink 16 to 20 ounces of water. Take many clay or activate a charcoal
that's zeolite to bind toxins. So those are binders that tend to stay in the gut zeolite could be
absorbed. It could be a key later as well. Before I begin my 30 minutes of rebounding prior to
hopping into the soda and then remineralize with greens and some sea salt following my soda.
I'm currently using the soda for 30 minutes and 160 degrees. I stay inside the soda for another 20
minutes to allow my body to continue to sweat and to slowly return to the normal body temperature.
Before I do skin brushing and then take a shower any info or guidelines that I should know as I
continue. Well, there's a well, many people cannot tolerate 30 minutes of soda at 160 degrees. So,
you're able to tolerate that and really sweat. So what's the benefit of doing a soda is you're
sweating. You're helping to take pressure off of your liver because you're using your skin as a
portal of detoxification so that can be really beneficial. Is there a temperature time goal to work
up to that would be best for breast cancer treatment? I really think you're at that maximum.
Typically, I don't recommend people do more than 30 minutes a day of soda and I typically recommend
people to start at 140 degrees. So, you're at 160 to 30 minutes already. I certainly wouldn't do any more
than that. So, I think you're doing great. Kudos to you. Fantastic. Personally, when I was doing a lot of
soda, I couldn't do more than 20 minutes. I just would go stir crazy. Even in my zip up soda, I
didn't have a soda. I have the other brand that still I just couldn't do it. A lot of people are
that way. I think it's a first start to use a soda like that. They can only do it for five minutes.
And as this kid panel anymore, you got to go slow and work up. So, you're doing great. You're kind at
the max right now. Long question. We've been on our full protocol for eight weeks. My boyfriend,
who has swam a cell carcinoma on his tonsil, has been swallowing better for at least two weeks now
and therefore has gained a couple of pounds. Yeah. With my breast cancer, I haven't detected any
shrinkage in tumor size. Is it too early? Well, remember, you might not detect shrinkage
in your tumor size. So, that is, you know, the the goal of cancer care, whether you're doing
standards of care or alternative care is to get it to stop growing. I mean, we can get it to stop
acting like cancer. Now, you want the ultimate goal is you want your body to clean it up and to
get rid of it and to dissolve it and break it down and kill those cells and then it would shrink.
But some cancers tend not to do that. It just is what it is. Some cancers will just stop growing.
And hey, that's a win as long as it's not blocking a lumen like if you're cold or something
or impede on, you know, blood flow or something, it's still a win. So,
but you do need to, I don't know that there's an url, is it too early to know? You just you just want
to see some progress in at least stopping the growth. That's that's something that you want to be
seeing. So, you want to be able to have a reliable way to monitor that as well. I feel fine,
but the cancer never made me ever feel sick. So, I can't judge it by that. By tumour of the right is
near the surface and quite large, like five centimeters. So, it makes me nervous.
But I know it was there for at least two years, misdiagnosis. So, maybe I'd be impatient for results.
I don't think you're being impatient. You want to see some change. You don't want it to be
getting larger. That's that's the that's the real thing. You want it to even stay in the same size
if you're like, I don't notice it any different in size, but I want it to shrink. Well,
that I would say, you know, continue to be patient to continue to move forward.
On the other side, the tumours are much smaller, but on the underside of my breast and closer to my
chest form. I lip nodes haven't shrunk. I have one on each side that are larger and sometimes hurt.
I don't know what to do next. I just never had to deal with anything like this. And talking to my
conventional docs always terrifies me. And there really no help because I wanted to do, you know,
going alternative route. I don't even know if I could convince them to run any more tests because they
refused to run my tumour markers. I asked my chiropractor to do it for me. The only ones that popped
was the CA 153 at 29.8 and 25 was the upper limit. And I did that five weeks ago. So if you have
a tumour marker test that shows positive meaning above the normal range, then you can use that for a
marker. You can even use it to a marker test if it shows if it's within the normal range,
but it's at the high end. Or you can run your tumour markers and let's say they're all within the
normal range and then you run them again. They're still within the normal range, but they've changed
dramatically. You certainly don't look at if it's if it's moved through four points, five points,
but if it's jumped 10 points, then you start going up. So those are valuable things to look at.
I don't know what to do next. Well, tumour marker tests are inexpensive to run. So you could run them
on a monthly basis to, before now, if you can't really assess any other way. So be patient to
another cheek swab. I don't think to it another cheek swab at this time is necessary.
Looking at some other ways to test objectivity would be something. Maybe you can, if your
contractor can ask for an ultrasound, that would be another objective test. So maybe ask your
contractor that. And like I said, yes, tumour markers rerun. Yes, you can do that on a monthly basis.
I bones get MRI and CT in mid September didn't indicate the cancer was anywhere else, but I don't
know how this works and are all the supplements, et cetera. I'm taking putting up a reasonable
strong shield against metastasis. Well, you're putting up the best shield you can from an alternative
perspective. Even if you did all that the oncologist has to do still doesn't mean that's, you know,
doing everything you can from the way you're body is dealing with the cancer. So there's lots of
people that do everything their oncologist tells them to do what they still get metastasis.
That's every day. So you just, you know, just trying to use your best judgment in the recording.
Sorry for the long question, but I need help to navigate it. I don't even know what questions to ask.
The practitioner who is muscle testing us each week says our organ systems are testing strong.
Indicating that we're on the right path, but they did not have as many of the same kind of patients.
I need to watch certain videos, read certain sections in your book. Again, so please just let me know
what those would be. I just don't know where to start. I think you are moving forward. You're doing
the right thing. I think the biggest thing is you want to be using your best objective way and
subjective way of measuring if there's any growth. So if you, if your tumors are very palpable
and you can kind of, you know, with the best reasonable judgment, tell if it's growing or not,
that might be your best unit of measure right now. Certainly, since the CA 153 was positive,
I would run that again. And it's, there's value in running your, your, your, other blood tests,
just a, a CBC and a, I could think that a violent panel in the three months as well,
that your kind of practice should be a little bit lower. My oncologist doesn't like how much you wait.
I have lost. You know, I can eat it all the time. Tatoes, brown rice, pumpkin seeds,
pecans, origins, any thoughts, any ideas, they want me to start boost. But I'm not a fan of that.
What are your thoughts? Well, I don't think boost is really going to help you gain weight.
If you are eating, you know, maybe good to start counting your calories. If you're eating, you know, a ton
of calorie and you're still losing weight is that is a concern. So, but the, you know, what, you know,
there's, there's a limited amount of things that you could do about that.
There was, there, I do have a video of cakexia, multiple. I think I have a blog post on cakexia too,
that I go over some different ideas. Let me look at them really quick. I can share it with you.
Make sure it's still on our site.
Yeah, cancer cakexia, weight loss and another, like a three, three-year-old blog post on cakexia.
So, if you just go to our main website and then you search the top of the website where you have
that little hourglass thing right there and you just search cakexia, then you'll see the multiple
blog post on that because that's the term that is given to a person with cancer that is eating,
you know, plenty, seemingly plenty of food, but are continuing to lose weight. So, there's some
hints that I give in those videos. I actually have several videos on cakexia, that might help.
Okay, that's on the chat. I've been using my true-life flip-bat and the inside metal.
Inside, the metal inside the unit is arrested. Is that expected or should I be doing something special
with the water? So, there is a video on the module on both the right course and on the member site
in the right section of the member site on how to clean your ion problem. So, just watch that video
on how to clean your propane flow away. Now, if you're ion pro-wave, if you're using 100 times already,
probably need to replace that. But, if you're only using it 20 times or 30 times and you notice that,
then you should probably clean it if you've ever cleaned it. I used the Thurosage Sonna,
the Thurosage guy, Robbie, told me to work up to 45 minutes at 165. I normally could do this once I
went over time because I was distracted. Other days, I don't last that long. I get in, if I get out,
if I start feeling, I start feeling a lot. So, you're saying that's too long. Well,
that's just my opinion. So, my opinion is 30 minutes max and 165, it's pretty hot. The person who
asked that other question is on 160, that's pretty hot. If you could tolerate it and you're
you are sweating good, the whole purpose is to sweat. So, if you could sweat at 120 degrees,
then you're really under 75. I don't think you're really increasing core body temperature that much
more at a higher temperature. So, that's the other idea of hypothermia, as if you could increase
core body temperature. You could help kill the cancer by increasing core body temperature. But,
it's difficult to measure really how well you're increasing core body temperature. You can
certainly just take a thermometer and stick it under your tongue and see if you raise your
temperature. But, really, the data on core body temperature raised in killing cancer is you really
have to raise core body temperature up to a hundred and three hundred, four degrees of chance that
you're going to produce that kind of fever state. Even a hundred eighty degrees in the sun is pretty slim.
We really, the purpose of the sun in my mind is really to sweat and to help you take pressure
after a living. The last three to four weeks have very strong muscle cramp in both my legs,
especially among the knees. What would be the reason the last one was so strong that could not say and
stand. Can this be connected to the tumor? Do I need a cheek swab? No, not really for this cramping
in your legs. Could that be related to the tumor? No, probably not. You have to think of like
types of intermittent claudication, types of you concerned with blood clots. You might want to go to
your doctor and get them checked out for that. If it is just muscle cramping in your thighs,
so you're saying it's above the knees. If it's in the back of your legs and your hamstrings,
it certainly hamstrings are very common to cramp with your deficient minerals and that's a
possibility. If you just started working out and you haven't been working out, your muscles can cramp
due just to blood flow issues with them. So there's multiple things that can be going on that you may
want to get an examination by a local doctor. There's no way for me to diagnose that, you know,
over a chat like this. There's just too many possibilities. If you have been vaccinated,
you've got to be thinking about possible blood clots. If you haven't been vaccinated,
but you're around a lot of people that have been vaccinated, you've got to be thinking of shedding
blood clots. You just have to be thinking of those things. So you want to make sure you move
those kinds of things out. So that my boyfriend could keep his weight up because he couldn't swallow well.
We loaded up his protein smoothies with duck butter and coconut oil. Don't know if those are on
your cancer diet plan, but lots of fat calories are easy way to go. I think you're referring back
to the person with the kexia issue. Yeah, that could help with body weight too. Really,
when you think of trying to keep a person's body weight or increased body weight, you've got to think
of carbohydrates and it's colder, intuitive with cancer, but you've got to, you have to deal with
problem at hand. And increasing good fats is very good for you in a lot of ways.
And increasing carbohydrates can help increase weight too.
I want to spell the word that we're talking about. So I'm talking about the kexia. What's a good
question? How do you spell kexia? So you spell it like this.
Car kexia. That's only a smoothies. Funny word, it's Latin.
Wheel turkey tail mushroom capsules and a dose of fiber vector down and then help with my prostate
cancer. Well, turkey tail mushrooms, probably one of my favorite mushrooms. Certainly a favorite
mushroom cancer, right? There's more data on turkey tail mushrooms and cancer than
than we can shake a stick at. So turkey tail is also called Coriolis Mersecaler.
There's other varieties of Coriolis as well. So we use a lot of turkey tail mushrooms and I do
like other mushroom blends as well. So the only, the only mushroom that you ever have to worry about
with any type of cancer is mushroom called lion's mane. Lion's mane is really good for your brain.
It's a really good to help. Actually, it's been shown to help grow neural tissue. So you don't want to
use lion's mane typically with brain tumors because the thought process, and there's been no
research that this actually happened with the thought process that helps grow neural tissue,
couldn't help grow a neural cancer. So typically, you don't use lion's mane for brain cancer,
but you could use, but lion's mane also wouldn't be used for a cancer in the prostate or in the breast.
Lion's mane is helps with brain function. Lion's mane is shown to help people with
even with some forms of dementia, and just loss of memory, and just as we age, and as we're under a
lot of stress, lion's mane can be, but that's not the question. So turkey tail is a great
immune modulator. All the mushrooms really are immune modulators, but they will help when you
need an immune stimulation. So they are great with any of the cancers. They are great with any infections.
So lion talkie, Rishi, turkey tail, chaga, those are really some of the great ones for
all the cancers. With a dose of Iverbectid, very possibly that could help that work as well.
I don't know any data on that specifically taking those together, but I don't think there's any
harm in any of that. There's really no downsides at using turkey tail. The only downside is
the one I mentioned, lion's mane and brain cancer. Yes, we were doing sweet potatoes in a zekial
bread too. I think talking to the space here too. You don't anything about uncle adjunct pathway
one to three. I am tried number two, which has frankincense, quercetin, and curcumin.
I do know about those. These are, this is like a system of different specific nutrition for
cancer for cancer patients. Quite honestly, I don't know how they get away with maybe their products,
what they do. If you look at some of their other product names, they're going to have issues
at the FDA. But these frankincense is a great essential oil for cancer, quercetin is an anti-inflammatory
flavonoid, has saved as curcumin. Anybody can do a Google search on curcumin and cancer,
just search curcumin at cancer, you'll probably find 600 newgal pages of research papers on curcumin
cancer. We get trouble recommending curcumin. I got in trouble with the state boards because it was
one of my five faves for cancers, curcumin, and it didn't like me saying that. It's like good
to say, since it's your research that I pulled out to show this, I just unbelievable. Coffee edema
talk again. I started doing these about two months ago, and my most recent CT scan shows
thickening in my paratodeum. I oncologist is saying, this progress, this is progress of disease. I
also have other areas that all of a sudden became active again by liver. Could this be sensitivity
to the coffee in this function? If you have a sensitivity, if you had a food sensitivity, it's not
going to cause cancer to grow. Your coffee isn't very little coffee and being absorbed in doing
a coffee edema. You're just stimulating your vagal nerve cell. I think there's just a coincidence
that you started the coffee edema. I don't think there's any cure relation there. We've heard
your video about glucose pyruvate. Can we measure the HIF-1 in a blood test?
No, not that I know, and we're really talking about HIF-1 gene that helps convert
the end product of glycolysis into the product needed to go into the cramps cycle.
And when we have a lot of defects on the HIF-1 gene, then we can get a back-up of pyruvate
acid and then you can end up birding that in the cell as energy in anaerobic state. So that
really is the warberg effect in process. So HIF-1 genes stimulate the warberg effect in a cancer
and which means you're birding, you're mainly using glycolysis to make energy,
not using the prep cycle to make energy. It's an inefficient way that cancer cells could grow.
And that's what's been built is the warberg effect since I don't warberg discovered that
way back many decades ago. And now we'll be at genetics. They're realizing that people that have
HIF-1 gene defects tend to have a greater chance of their cancer being fed through that back-through
glycolysis. Those people should probably lower their glucose, lower their sugar content
if they're diet, if they have cancer. There's no way to measure that directly.
Is there a part of genetics test results that let us know what is usually in our cancer?
Is that discovered in the genetics course? Well, yes and no in a sense that we
lay that out in the genetic summary. So if we think there's a piece of your gene, so there's no way
that you can just say, even if I have HIF-1 gene defects that I have cancer, there's no way you can say
this proves that you are feeding your cancer through glycolysis. Therefore, you should go out of
ketogenic diet that would be best for you. Just because a person has genetic defects doesn't mean that
gene is necessarily expressed in a way that it is functioning much worse than if you didn't have
genetic defects. It's just a matter of reason. So you have genetic defects in the HIF-1 gene, you have a
greater propensity to that possibility that your cancer is going to be fed mainly more through
glycolysis than if you didn't have an HIF-1 gene defect. So therefore, we would recommend in that person's
case that doing, you know, you know, time restricted eating would be, you know, better for that person
staying off of sugar is more completely as possible would be better for that person. So that's where
you can get hints or clues through your genes. You're not going to get any absolute concrete specifics
because it's impossible because it's not how your genes work just because defects in a certain gene
doesn't mean that that gene is expressed in a way that it's causing major problems. It just means
that I have a greater propensity to have those problems that could be associated with that gene.
Hypo-functioning. So that's how you got to look at genes. So, you know, we would like to say
on because this person has this gene, you're going to have that problem but it's just not that simple.
Your body is so much more complex than that. Your body is compensated for just different gene
defects that your body is, you know, trying to function as best as possible. So it's best to understand
genetics in a light of the bigger picture and in light of you're not trying to quote unquote
treat the gene. You're getting an idea with genetics of different clues that are going on with your
body that, hey, maybe I should be taking more curcumin or maybe I should be eating, you know,
this way a little bit or maybe I should, you know, look at my genetic picture with dairy. I probably
shouldn't be eating dairy, you know, so it gives you clues that way. So, that's how you want to look
at genetics. That's why we, you know, give you the full report but then we give you the
genetic summary and then we give you the, what we think are the best action sticks. So,
that's not going to tell you specifically what's feeding your kids or that's a functional aspect
of a hard genetic aspect. Any other questions? Okay, remember we will be closed on the 26th.
And I think we're, right now we're going to be open to the after New Year's,
so read the place orders and something should be a problem. And then remember that last week,
next week will be the last week for Monday's Zoom call. So next Monday will be our last
Monday's Zoom call for a while. We may start about forgetting with Sprendo.
So we can just push them all to Wednesday and questions to Wednesday. All right, thanks for everybody
for being on. I know that I'll be praying for all of you and ask that you keep us in your
prayers as well. And I love y'all. We'll talk to you next week. Talk to you in a bit. Bye-bye.